would you rather always come prematurely  or never come at all well this is my  theory is that in the porn world like  most guys gravitate towards one or the  other where either they're like it's  hard for them to [ __ ] for a long time  because they're going to come too fast  or it's hard for them to finish because  it's hard to come I personally am the  person who's like closer to like nutting  at any given moment like I'm genuinely  into it but if I had to choose one  always come prematurely so like even if  I'm on round four I still come  prematurely  or never come at all Jesus Christ these  are terrible but you prefer  that's so nice of you  have never come at all means that I just  get to be out there with just a [ __ ]  just an arm on me just going I am  but it's not about you